[Musique]
i think
American policies are usually dictated
by amazing ignorance in the case of
Libya for example I think that the
Americans who got involved and the
French
[Musique]
bonjour
thinkerview Je vous salue de Berkley en
[Musique]
Californie je vois que en principe en
théorie l'Amérique pense qu'elle a une
économie libre et qui est réglé par le
marché ouvert mais en vérité comme tout
le monde c'est euh des le dollar est
très faible parce que l'Amérique fait
beaucoup plus
d'impimportation que de l'exportation
et ce système qui euh qui n'est pas
très très solide euh ce que on a vu des
crises récemment surtout en 2007 2008 et
dans cette crise là les banques non non
seulement des États-Unis mais les
banques mondiaux ont eu une crise manque
de capitaux qui a été soulevé par la les
fonds illégaux et les fonds noirs comme
on dit en anglais de du trafic de drogue
et on ne sait pas le grandeur de le
trafic de de drogue mais on a fait une
estimation que
peut-être il y a
une milliards de dollars par an qui sont
euh blanchi dans les banques et il y a
eu
une un officier de des Nations Unies qui
a dit il y avait des banques qui
auraient échoué pendant cette crise là
s'il n'y avait pas eu euh cette
euh remémédiie des des fonds illégaux
dans le trafic de
drogue il y a deux façons de voir le
rôle de la guerre contre la drogue pour
moi le fait principal le plus important
c'est que euh le prix des drogues est
beaucoup plus élevé que qu'il y aurait
euh s'il n'y avait pas cette guerre
contre le drog ça veut dire que les
grands euh rois de la drogue euh il il
ils approuvent cette guerre contre la
drogue parce c'est la source de leur
profit et c'est la drogue devient comme
une une taxe euh sur les gens ordinaires
qui enrichi les les riches et ces fonds
enfin ils arrivent dans les banques
américaines euh les banques font des
arrangement spécifiques pour recevoir
ces fonds pr privés il y a la banque
ordinaire et puis à côté la banque
privée qui reçoit des fortunes illégales
comme celle par exemple de du frère du
feu président de du Mexique et comme ça
c'est
euh le résultat c'est que
la drogue est même plus
important dans l'économie
qu' ne serait si nous nousavions pas pas
cette guerre contre la drogue
oui c'est vrai que pour
les pour les états quand je parle par
exemple de la Californie
là notre premier
produit agronome c'est le
marijuana mais c'est vrai que il n'y a
pas une taxe sur le marijuana par ce
n'est pas légal ça commence à changer un
petit peu mais en principe c'est illégal
ce n'est pas taxé
et le gouvernement souffre euh
l'économie c'est différent parce que
même si nous parlons maintenant de
l'héroï qui proviennent de
l'Afghanistan les grands profits non ne
sont pas fait en
Afghanistan le pays de production il ils
sont dans le pays de consommation
parce
que on estime que peut-être 80 ou plus
80 % du profit est fait dans ces pays-là
et même les autres euh profits sont
aussi banqués dans un pays où les
banques sont fermes et garanties
c'est-à-dire les
États-Unis il y a eu deux moments où les
États-Unis se sont intervenus en
Afghanistan le premierre était contre
les les les russes et soviétiques en 19
79 et le deuxe évidemment après le le 11
septembre en
2001 le résultat de ces deux
interventions c'est que
l'Afghanistan qui a toujours eu euh
de de lopium et de hashich de marijuana
mais avant la première
américaine intervention américaine
n'était pas une puissance dans le marché
international la consommation était
locale et même les américains ils sont
allés pour avoir
avoir un été de drogue
sans sans danger dans les années 70
c'était le ce qu'on appelit le la piste
des des hippies le hippy trail
mais de presque rien en 1979
jusqu'à maintenant maintenant c'est
presque 90 % de l'héroï internationale
provient de de l'Afghanistan et même aux
États-Unis si je peux ajouter un autre
chiffre il y avait euh le percentage de
l'héroï aux États-Unis qui provenait de
ce qu'on appelle le croissant dehor
c'était zéro en
1979 et selon le gouvernement en
1980 ça a sauté jusqu'à 60
[Musique]
personnes on voit à Washington il y a ce
grand problème de la drogue et il y a
des des sociologues des médecins toutes
sortes d'experts qui disent que
il il faut vraiment changer la loi et
surtout pour commencer légaliser le
marinoana mais c'est un sujet interdit à
Washington personne c'est si on veut si
on veut poursuivre une carrière
politique il faut pas se mêler de ce
problème et la raison je pense c'est
parce que il y a trop trop d'argent et
trop de profit à qui provient de la
situation actuelle
et c'est pour ça c'est un exemple pas le
seul où notre démocratie ne fonctionne
pas parce que les l'argent interdit la
discussion des vrais problèmes dont la
drogue est vraiment une des grands
problèmes qui rouinent
euh les les la vie dans dans les grandes
villes euh le inner city comme nous
disons en anglais
et pendant 50 ans on a attendu une
changement de des lois mais c'est
interdit comme sujet c'est est-ce que
c'est parce que les les les politiciens
ne sont pas libres oui ils sont libres
de le discuter s'ils veulent mais ils
savent très bien que ce sera la fin de
leur leur carrière alors pour ça il le
discut
euh j'ai dans ma vie je n'ai passé que 6
mois à Washington je je connais
Washington très mal mais j'ai vu une une
une exemple au congrès de la de
de la façon dans laquelle on n'est pas
permis de parler de la
drogue je faisais partie d'une
commission secrète CD on on recevait des
discours dans une chambre privée pour
une des commissions de la
chambre du Congrès
et
le le président de cette commission a
dit au comm ement que il y a un mot
qu'il voulait pas absolument voulait pas
entendre dans la discussion et cette mot
était legalization
légalisation
et je me suis demandé pourquoi mais plus
tard j'ai fait de recherches j'ai trouvé
que c ce représentant dans la chambre
avait un frère avec une
qu'est-ce qu'on dit est
euh il était avocat et dans son bureau
des avocats il avait un très grand
client c'était un des plus grands rois
de la drogue dans la ville de New York
alors c'était une source de profil euh
qui qui aurait été abîmé et la drogue
avait été légalisé et c'est c'est c'est
pour ça je crois pour cet individu mais
qui était un individu assez important
d'ailleurs euh qui voulait pas entendre
le mot
legalisation c'est vrai aussi il y a des
grandes bureaucraties comme le di le qui
est chargé de d'empêcher la la drogue et
comme tes les prisons et toutes ces
bureaucratie deviennent une partie du
système qui gouverne le pays ils veulent
pas avir un changement c'était comme
dans les années 20 au aux États-Unis
avec la prohibition euh que de plus en
plus c'était évident qu'il fallait
changer mais il y avait à cette époque
aussi une grande résistance qui
provenait de la bureaucratie et ailleurs
quand enfin on a légalis l'alcool c'est
le moment où euh on a
haussé la la poursuite des drogues et
les gens qui anciennement cherchai de
les boîtes de de l'alcool maintenant il
cherchaient le marijuana pour la
première fois c'était tout de suite
après le le la fin de la prohibition de
l'alcool j'ai une faiblesse c'est que
j'invente des mots de temps en temps
comme la politique profonde et aussi
j'ai inventé cette phrase
supramonde il y a en anglais un underwor
sousmonde et qui fait une puissance sur
le gouvernement d'en bas mais c'est
beaucoup plus faible que les puissances
sur le gouvernement d'en haut et
j'appelle tout cette force privée les
corporations mais aussi des individus
des Très Riches
euh les très riches qui s'occupent de la
politique je je les je les appelle le
soupremonde et dans mon
bouquin ici la route vers le désordre
mondial
j'ai même donné une définition que je
vais lire et pour ça il me faudra mes
lunettes une instant
supramonde
euh la le royaume de la société riche et
privilégié qui est le théâtre d'une
influence efficace exercée sur le
gouvernement par le pouvoir privé bien
que le supremonde ne soit pas
institutionnalisé ni autorisé
formellement exercer une telle influence
il inclut d'abord ceux dont l'influence
s'exerce à travers leur richesse qu'elle
soit administré personnellement ou plus
traditionnellement par le billet des
fondations exonorées d'impôts et les
projets qu'ell soutiennent et
deuxièmement les représentants des prem
ce terme doit être distingué de celui de
frériich Lundberg les super riches
c'est-à-dire les 60 familles les plus
riches des États-Unis dont il a prédit
d'une manière éronée en
1967 dans son ouvrage 6ty families
qu'elle continuerait à dominer les
États-Unis autant que classe et
gouvernement de
l'argent les récents classements u
établi par la revue Forbes dans des 400
états-uniens les plus riches démontre
que lunberg s'est
trompé sur deux plans les plus riches
héritiers du M 67 ne sont
magitoritairement pas les plus riches
d'aujourd'hui et les plus riches
d'aujourd'hui ne sont pas nécessairement
ceux qui
projetteent leur richesse dans le
pouvoir politique par ailleurs le
soupremonde n'est pas une classe mais
une catégorie ça c'est très important il
faut pas penser que cette classe est
unifié les riches les riches se
connaissent euh mais il n'ag ils
n'agissent pas d'une façon un solidaire
il est éronné de concevoir comme une
règle institutionnelle l'influence du
suamonde telle qu'était exercé à travers
la société
Bilderberg la commission trilatéral ou
le conseil de relations
étrangères cependant il existe des
cabales moins connu et habituellement
sérète qui prospère au sein de ces
milieux
supramonde par exemple en France la
cercle piné ou le safari club c'est ma
définition c'est vrai qu'ils sont
organis organisés c'est vrai qu'il
existe par exemple Davos chaque année il
existe la société Bilderberg il existe
Commission Trilatérale et le fait même
de toutes ces organisations différentes
indique que c'est une situation plutôt
pluraliste que unifiée mais dans au
milieu il faut vraiment se rendre compte
que par
exemple pas tout le monde le sait mais
c'est vrai que en
19 74 je crois le gouvernement Wilson en
Angleterre a été bouleversé a mis à la
porte
et aussi de Gaul à la fin de son pouvoir
avait des problèmes avec son service
d'intelligence
et nous avons appris plus tard qu'il
existait une cercle piné qui prenait euh
euh qui était fier de la fête qui elle
avait pu
élire Madame Thatcher en Angleterre et
et alors il y a pas
même organisation mais même des des
puissances profondes au milieu de ce
suprmonde parce que la force de l'argent
c'est très très for par exemple euh nous
savons très bien que il y a eu deux
haussements de tarif pour la pétrole la
première en
72 je dirais 19 72 13 et le 2è
1979 80 euh nous savons que Nixon était
responsable pour le premier parce que ça
a aidé ces projets
à pour
régler la région du
golf iranien est-ce qu'on dit la Golf en
tout parce que les prof fit pour l'Iran
l'Arabie Saoudite qui provenait du
haussement de pétrole payé pour leur
importation des armes américaines avec
des des équipes
pour pour enseigner l'emploi de ses
armes et tout ça le deuxème évidemment
sous le présidence du président Carter
ce n'était pas ça n'aidit pas de tout sa
politique au contraire c'était
responsable pour sa chute mais je crois
que les républicains avaient des
contacts dans les pays pétrolières et
peut-être bipi en particulier euh ont
encourager OPEC de hausser euh le prix
de pétrole et par cette façon on a vu
l'élection presque simultanée de s en
Angleterre et puis aussi euh reen aux
États-Unis et vraiment l'élection du
président
Rean était le début d'une nouvelle
époque aux États-Unis où il y a eu une
grande haussement de subventions pour
les des budgets militaires et pour les
budgets sucret de CIA le CIA commencé
une guerre en Afghanistan
et tout ça et on voit un résultat
dans la société civil que avant
1980 les classes riches et pauvres
s'approchait dans le revenu il y avait
une diminution de la disparité entre les
riches et les pauvres mais depuis ce
cette année-là depuis 1980
c'est le contraire que maintenant les
riches deviennent beaucoup plus riches
et les pauvres beaucoup plus pauvres et
nous sommes PIR maintenant que l'Europe
dans
cette dans dans dans ce ce statistique
c'est-à-dire avant avant 1940 80 euh
l'Angleterre était euh une pays de
classe avec des riches et des pauvres et
les États-Unis moins maintenant c'est le
contraire l'Amérique est plus divisée
entre les riches et les pauvres que
l'Angleterre ou presque n'importe quel
autre pays euh en Europe sauf la Russie
quand je parle de la supramande il faut
pas penser que le la supramande est
divisée par une
grande grand fossé euh du gouvernement
non c'est la source des gens surtout
dans le passé les gens entrraaient de du
supronde ils sont entrés dans le
gouvernement et surtout au poste euh le
secrétaire de finances secrétaire du du
trésorerie est-ce qu'on dit
euh mais aussi il y a une institution au
milieu du gouvernement qui était qui
recevait beaucoup plus les la pensée les
direction de Wall Street que le reste du
gouvernement et c'était le CIA le CIA
euh le CIA quand a été créé c'était
vraiment une création de Wall Street
Truman était le président il n'était pas
très à l'aise avec cette idée d'avoir
une service d'intelligence dans de
conditions de paix mais c'était Wall
Street qui a insisté CIT Wall Street qui
a gagné et c'est très intéressant de
voir que Truman insistait que le chef
dans son son époque le chef n'était
jamais de Wall Street toujours de
l'Amérique centrale
surtout de de
l'armée avant Allan Dallas qui était
évidemment Wall Street purure
euh n'y avait jamais un un chef qui
provenait de Wall Street mais les
sous-chefs t tous les souschef que nous
connaissons SEP je connais SEP ils
étaient tous W Street et en plus il y a
ce qu'on appelle le Society register ça
veut
dire des gens de richesse hérité euh la
grande société de New York 6 de ce 7
étit de cette société ce social register
alors dès le commencement c'était une
création de Wall Street et enfin
pour des raisons techniques dont je
parle dans mon
book mon bouquin American War Machine
c'était trum qui a fait introduire Allan
Dallas comme un de ses souschef dans le
CIA mais le moment que les républicains
ont enfin gagné le présidence en
1952 c'était la fin des chefs de l'armée
c'est G Beatles Smith et c'est le
commencement de l'époque de dallus un
dallus qui était au CIA et are Dall son
frère qui était le secrétaire d'État et
c'est nous avons vu à cette époque une
politique pure de Wall Street commençant
avec
euh l'assistance pour soulever le
président élu en Iran monsieur mosadeek
pour sauver le
le la compagnie pétrolière
anglo-iranienne qui maintenant s'appelle
BP et deuxièmement tout de suite après
en Guatemala
pour
sauver United Fruit
contre
en contre un autre président élu arbens
élu pas une façon
tique il faut se rappeler que Truman
en en
créant cette CIA il pensait que ce
serait un service d'intelligence de
renseignement de de trouver des des
nouvelle de tous les pays mais euh dès
le
commencement sous la direction des gens
de Wall Street ils sont entrés dans les
opérations c'est-à-dire des des
opérations criminel en général dans le
le reste du monde parce que c'était à
cause en partie de de menace soviétique
à l'époque la première opération C et de
mettre argent dans l'élection italienne
de 1948
et on disait que les les Russes
faisaient la même chose alors il il
fallait faire la même chose mais dans
les années 50 oui toutes les opérations
du CIA des grandes opérations ils
étaient euh pour le bien du Wall Street
et euh on on ne sait pas ça parce
que le CIA a aussi s mêlé dans le
sud-est l'Asie en commençant d'abord en
Thaïlande et puis Birmanie et puis le
Laos et enfin d'une façon beaucoup plus
grande
vietnamment je dire dirait que dès le
dès le
[Musique]
commencement les
interventions du CIA étai pour les buts
définis par Wall Street d'abord c'est à
ce moment-ci nous parlons du Conseil des
relations extérieures de Council of
foreign relations qui avait eu une
discussion ce qu'on devrait faire en
Guatemala avant que le CIA a commencé
alors premièrement
discussion à New York décision et puis
décision communiqué à
Washington c'était c'était sous
eisenhauer qui était très volontairement
il était d'accord mais la façon de
d'influencer la politique c'était à
surtout à travers le CIA et ça a été
exécuté par le CIA et je je vois la même
chose plus tard avec Vietnam parce que
euh Vietnam euh était un pour moi la la
vraie raison euh pour avoir intervenu
euh en VI au Vietnam c'était à cause que
avec les développements techniques de
des recherches de pétrole pour la
première fois on pouvait trouver de de
pétrole au-dessous de la mer et on
savait dès dès le commencement des
années 50 qu'il y avait beaucoup d'huile
dans au au sous la mer chinoise le le la
mer entre le Vietnam et
l'Indonésie et nous voyons à cette
époque des grandes interventions des C
au Vietnam et à l'Indonésie et après ça
les euh la signature des contrats avec
les les compagnies américaines pour
développer le l'huile sous la mer au
Vietnam au Cambodge au Thaïlande et
surtout à
l'Indonésie j'ai débuté vraiment dans
mes recherches en cherchant la raison
pour laquelle les Américains se sont
intervenus dans la politique
indonésienne en
1965 avec le résultat un grand mass cre
de peut-être millions de personnes
personnes civiles femmes
enfants toute une classe des
institutions dans les écoles parce
qu'ils étaient dans un parti communiste
mais un parti communiste assez pacifique
qui comptait gagner une élection ça
c'était une une des grandes
interventions euh des États-Unis non
seulement le CIA mais aussi l'armée
américaine avec le avec toutes sortes de
choses mais c'était pour le
pétrole le réérique à la fois c'était
paré des ressources naturelles de la
région on a parlé de caoutchou on a
parlé de
étin tout ça ce nétait pas fausse c'est
il comptait surtout une des plus grands
moins moins discuté mais très important
c'était le vfam tungsten je connais pas
le mot en français j'espère que c'est
tungsten c'est tungsten en anglais et
c'est absolument nécessaire pour une
acier fort pour les mement dans les
chats blindés et cetera et absolument
nécessaire et ça provenait dans cette
époque de la Chine qui qui était
maintenant hors hors de question et
aussi
dans l'Asie de
sud-est ça c'était vrai aussi mais le
pétrole a dépassé je crois les autres
surtout le caoutchu parce que maintenant
la plupart de notre caoutchu ça provient
de la la pétrole euh c'est artificiel
et on on vait voir dans les statistiques
euh la commerce entre l'Asie du Sud-Est
et l'Amérique était basé sur le pétrole
les investissements qu'on a vu dans
l'Asie du Sud-Est une grande partie part
aussi du Japon mais le Japon aussi était
son son économie après la guerre était
une cré des des
Américains parce qu'on pense à cette
époque que la politique américaine était
définie par la guerre froide contre la
Russie contre l'Union soviétique on se
demande euh
que en quelle partie cette cette guerre
froide et était vrai et en quelle partie
c'était une espèce de de masque pour les
raison plus capitaliste de de Wall
Street mon opinion personnellement j'ai
j'y a réfléchi beaucoup parce que
j'étais jeune à C cette époque mais je
le rappelle bien c'est que en partie la
peur de l'Union soviétique était réel et
et et était vrai c'est-à-dire
que je crois pas jamais jamais l'Union
soviétique aurait
invadé l'Europe deouest avec ses ses
division en l'Europe de l'Est et ça
c'est le grand mythe de l'UTAN et quand
j'étais dans le gouvernement j'ai
commencé à questionner ce mythe je je ne
croyais pas à cette époque je le VO pas
maintenant mais je crois c'est très très
possible que les les partis communistes
en Italie et en France auraient gagné
leurs élections et c'est parce que le
CIA est intervenu pour empêcher C ce
résultat que nous voyons maintenant une
Europe non communiste et de mon point de
vue personnel je je n'aime pas les
moyens euh qui ont été utilisés euh pour
protéger l'Europe de l'Ouest mais je
suis très content que nous voyons
pas une France qui a subi la même
politique après les guerre que par
exemple la Pologne parce que j'ai vécu
en Pologne c'était pas si pire j'ai je
connaissais les gens dans le
gouvernement socialiste ils étaient mes
copains mais
euh c'est c'était triste pour la Pologne
et je suis content que la Pologne est
maintenant libre de l'influence russe
et pour moi personnellement je crois
que les événements en France aent été
aussi triste si les les communistes
étaient mis au pouvoir ce sont des
sujets qui sont très difficile à
discuter
mais j'ai dit tout ça pour admettre
qu'il y avait un élément de vérité au
commencement dans la guerre froide mais
aussi il faut voir que quand cette
guerre s'est développée ça a été de plus
en plus
influencé par euh les intérêts privés du
supremonde
j'ai j'ai j'ai je vais inclure
maintenant aussi les grandes
corporations internationales de l'époque
qui étaient surtout les les corporations
de pétrole comme Standard Oil ex ce que
nous appelons maintenant exon mobile
Texaco
euh c'est la guerre froide s'est
changé pendant des années pour devenir
une façon pour protéger des intérêts de
ces grandes
corporations non pas
ement en Europe mais en parti en Europe
avec le Truman doctrine euh pour
garantir une grissce non communiste
c'était admis à la au à cette époque
c'était admis que c'était pour garantir
euh que le pétrole de l'Arabie saoudite
pourrait pourrait être vendu en Europe
parce que
les grandes compagnes Corporation ne
voulaient pas que ça provienne aux
États-Unis parce qu'ils avaient encore
une production domestique ici
auanis il fallait que ce pétrole aille à
l'Europe et pour ça il fallait avoir une
Grèce non communiste ça c'était un
commencement de de mélange entre la
vraie guerre froide et les intéressants
de le Corporation mais plus tard c'était
presque purement les corporations
oui je viens d'écrire un petit article
sur la la situation actuelle au milieu
de euh
2013 en Syrie parce que c'est un choix
qui s'est reproduit m fois dans
l'histoire
américaine choix entre une politique
militaire et une politique diplomatique
euh c'était au commencement du mois de
mai que euh les États-Unis et la Russie
se sont accordés qu'il fallait euh
convenir une convention peut-être à
Genève pour chercher une solution
internationale diplomatique au
problèmes syriens qui devenaiit de plus
en plus grave et qui menaçait de plus en
plus de grandir et de sortir au-delà des
frontières syriennes et de créer une
crise
euh au Liban en Irak et même peut-être
en en Turquie
euh parce qu'il y a des CDES partout
et euh j'étais très déçu que enfin Obama
qui est pris en position très
euh rétréci il ne voulait pas se mêler
dans cette effaire mais enfin sous la
pression des fauxcans euh à Washington
et elle
a accordé envoyé des armes des petites
armes mais des armes euh aux combattant
et c'est un c'est une blague parce que
déjà le CIA il avait envoyé non pas
seulement des armes mais aussi des euh
des spécialistes pour enseigner dans les
armes c'est un peu comme la Libye il y
avait une politique secret qui déjà
commençait cette politique ça ça c'est
très dangereux pour une solution euh
diplomatique international euh l'espoir
n'est pas tout à fait éteint mais c'est
beaucoup plus faible maintenant le
problème c'est que dans la Syrie comme
dans les autres pays dont j'ai parlé il
y a un problème de pétrole il maintenant
c'est de plus en plus le gaz avant
c'était l'huile le pétrole maintenant
c'est de plus en plus le gaz on a
découvert du gaz même en Syrie mais ce
qui est beaucoup plus important
c'est comment on dit un gaz field un
champ de
gaz une région de gaz sous terre c'est
sous la sous la Golfe qui est partagé à
moitié pour le Qatar moitié pour l'Iran
et c'est le c'est la région le plus
grand dans tout le monde le marché pour
ce gaz ce sera l'Europe et les conduit
de gaz ne passeront pas par Israël ils
passeront par la Syrie comme d'habitude
il y avait la première conduit de
pétrole de l'Arabie Saoudite passé par
l'Irak et enfin la Syrie à la
Méditerranée ça a été TER mené il y a
longtemps il y avait une autre conduit
qui était abîmé pendant la guerre d'Irak
mais maintenant c'est un choix euh Qatar
a dit eu monsieur Assad en Syrie il faut
que vous vous
démissionner nous voulons un
gouvernement plus musulmane qui
laisserait notre conduit de gaz de passé
de l'Irak à Turquie parce qu'il y a
maintenant une grande conduit de gaz
quand va construire le la ligne nabouo
en Turquie et Qatar voulait vendre son
gaz à cette ligne
mais à la fois simultanément l'Iran a
dit nous voulons aussi prendre de gaz de
cette même région et de l'envoyer en
Europe par une condu qui passerait Iran
euh
et Irak parce que maintenant l'Irak est
beaucoup plus proche à l'Iran que avant
et
enfin Syrie
et cette guerre
entre le gouvernement d'un côté et les
différentses parties
de entre les rebelles euh il le raison
et sétait subventionné surtout par le
Qatar qui a qui a déjà
euh payer je crois plus de 3 milliards
de dollars de subvention pour cette
révolte parce qu'ils veulent
avoir Assad à la porte pour avoir leur
conduit mais Assad est protégé
maintenant il il commence à gagner avec
l'appui deb là qui est directement
subventionné et en parti dirigé de
Terran en en en Iran et Assad a signé un
contrat officiel avec l'Iran pour avoir
un conduit de gaz qui passerait
directement on appelle ça je crois le le
le conduit de gaz
islamique qui passera de de de
l'Iran a maintenant un port qui
anciennement était un port assez petit
mais qui deviendra assurément beaucoup
plus grand à cause de gaz même là-bas
même en Syrie même
et comme la la GR la grande partie des
interventions de de l'Amérique et deess
n'importe où et surtout au
liby et en ir
il s'agissait du pétrole du gaz et la
Syrie n'est pas une exception euh mais
c'est plutôt c'était comme l'Afghanistan
même parce que le moment
où les États-Unis commençaient à
s'intéresser à la fin des avec le
taliban la fin la fin des années
1980 il avait on parlait de conduitire
de pétrole qui qui passerait de
Kazakhstan à Pakistan à travers
l'Afghanistan c'est pour ça l'unocal une
compagnie américaine a invité des gens
les représentants de taliban de venir à
Texas pour être enseigné dans les
affaires techniques euh c'est toujours
le pétrole quand quand on parle de
l'Amérique et son Petro dollar qui est
les bases de sa sa fortune
internationale
l'Amérique euh est divisée entre des
faucans et des colombes sur le le théma
de du Syrie euh et mais en Europe c'est
le même situation mais enore il y a une
division encore plus grave parce qu'il y
a deux sorte de des intérêts en Europe
des petits pays comme Autriche à l'Est
ils veulent avoir
euh de gaz aussitôt que possible ils
veulent pas être sous
euh l'influence trop profonde de de la
Russie alors ils invitent cette la
France au contraire euh qui avait des
intérêts historiques dans la région
et euh l'Autriche est peut-être une des
colombes de l'Europe et la France
actuellement est une des faucon de
l'Europe tel qu'elle était aussi dans la
cas de la Libye c'était Bernard Levi qui
a dans un sens débutter tous les
problèmes au liby en 19 2000
2011 c'est pour ça que c'est ces
problèmes de de gaz et de pétrole ne
sont pas simples il créent des des des
alliances régionales et surtout aussi la
Russie a position assez compliquée à
travers ce conduit de pétrole parce que
je j'imagine que la Russie préférait de
voit ni le le conduit de Qatar ni le
conduit de l'Iran parce que le marché de
pour le
gaz n'est pas
infini est limité et actuellement c'est
c'est le gaz
russe pour termin
je voudrais euh dire quelque chose à la
jeunesse qui assiste à cette interview
euh je voudrais parler de la raison pour
laquelle je fais mes recherches et j'ai
fait mes enquêtes
d'abord je je je viens du Canada qui est
un pays assez petit si on parle de du
nombre de gens et nous avons au Canada
l'impression que si nous avons une idée
pour améliorer le pays nous pouvons le
partager avec les dirigeants à ottoa
avec les membres du Parlement canadien
et même en vérité j'ai je l'ai fait un
petit peu quand j'étais jeune même avant
l'âge de 20 ans
euh et comme je suis arrivé aux
États-Unis j'avais la même illusion mais
vous savez très bien que c'est pas la
même chose aux États-Unis que euh et il
y a plus de gens en Californie seul je
crois que dans tout le Canada alors
c'est c'est dans une échelle tout à fait
différente et je dois dire que euh si
j'avais l'idée au commencement je
luttais contre l'intervention dans la
guerre du Vietnam je de ma carrière dans
la diplomatie je connaissais un tout
petit peu de la situation vietnamienne
pas beaucoup mais assez pour me
convaincre que les États-Unis ne devrai
pas entrer dans cette guerre pour pour
pour la santé américaine aussi autant
que la santé Vietnam vietnamienne
et j'ai bien appris que tout un
mouvement des milliers des milliers
presque de millions à la fin ils ont
assisté un tout petit peu à terminé
cette guerre
mais
mon ma
contribution personnelle était très très
petite et je n'ai pas maintenant
l'impression que mes idées vont changer
les États-Unis pas du tout mais quand
même je suis très content de faire ce
que je fais je je rencontre des gens que
j'adore comme des gens je suis dans une
chambre ici avec avec de copains que
j'ai rencontré dans un mouvement et dans
ces
mouvements je rencontre les gens que
j'aime et
aussi j'ai toujours l'idée que même si
je
cont contribue pas aux politiques de la
du présent que il y a toujours la
politique de l'avenir et que peut-être
je peux persuader des autres gens d'être
comme moi euh intéressé dans la justice
internationale dans la liberté
personnelle et dans la démocratie euh
c'est sur l'écran de le niveau de
Washington c'est un très mauvais
mouvement mouvement très mauvais moment
maintenant pour la justice la liberté à
la démocratie mais quand même je vois
que les
euh la mauvaise politique de
Washington crée une opposition euh et je
veux absolument je veux être parti de
cette opposition parce que j'ai la foi
dans la race humaine que nous avons une
tendance enfin
vers la démocratie vers la liberté
et euh vers la joie d'être euh libre
dans une s société libre et ouverte
et je suis très déçu si je ne pensais
pas que je pourrais contribuer un tout
petit peu à cet avenir et je veux
j'espère que parmi vous autres vous
autres la jeunesse euh il y aura des
gens qui vont avoir la même espoir de
participer dans l'avenir de notre pays
de de notre globe euh euh et notre race
humaine merci
beaucoup et il y a actuellement une
situation qu'on n'aurait pas prévu il y
a 20 ans en fait des comparaison entre
les États-Unis avec leur
surveillance universelle
et l'Allemagne de l'Est à l'époque de
stasie où il y avait la même chose et
c'est une des grandes indications que
depuis le 11 septembre nous avons
vraiment vu un grand changement aux
États-Unis on n'aurait pas prévu cette
surveillance universelle et ça c'était
un résultat de ce qu'on
appelle continuity of government
arrangements le COG continuité de
gouvernement qui avait été planifié
planifié pendant 20 ans par un
groupement des gens par en parti dans le
gouvernement et en parti dehors le plus
intéressant c'est que deux de ces gens
qui ont planifié était Donald ramsfeld
et Richard Shany qui étit au pouvoir à
Washington le le 11 septembre le
président Bush était en Floride et ces
jeux là ces deux gens-là ils ont fait
commencer implémenter les prov provision
de continuity of government
et on peut les résumés en trois
catégories d'abord surveillance
universelle sans mandat de d'une cour et
deuxièmement qui était beaucoup plus
pire je crois détention indéfinie sans
sans mandat d'un cours et troisièmement
euh
l'intervention euh permanent euh du de
l'armée de des militaires dans la
sécurité domestique euh des
États-Unis les points 2 et 3 étaient
contre les lois existants même on
pourrait dire contre la Constitution des
États-Unis le
vraiment il faut expliquer au à une
assistance française que l'idée euh de
détention
sans mandat indéfini ça contrevient une
des libertés les plus profondes et les
plus euh
traditionnelles de la tradition
anglosaxone ça ça a été donné par le
magna Carter dans l'année
1215 et depuis ce tempslà nous avons eu
ce qu'on appelle euh habus corpus qui
qui dit un cours euh c'est quelqu'un est
détenu dans 24 48 he mais mais bientôt
il faut euh produire
ce le type qui a été détenu et bien que
je crois que c'est horrible que nous
avons maintenant une surveillance
universelle euh pour trouver des
terroristes on a trouvé peut-être une
vingtaine une cinquantaine ça dépend de
votre définition
mais moins de certainement moins de 500
terroristes aux États-Unis on en
surveille tout le monde et et
permanemment tout le temps et ça ça
devenu une excuse pour contrôler le
public en
général pour créer une situation très
très similaire que ce que le le
romancier George Orwell a prévenu dans
son roman
1994 il s'est trompé de date mais il a
vraiment prévenu ce que nous avons
maintenant aux États-Unis et aussi le
trisème
point l'intervention des militaire dans
le d'une façon permanente euh dans la
sécurité domestique il y a aussi les
lois spécifiquement
américaines pass come tatus la qui
interdisait cela et ça tout à tout a
changé apparemment pour toujours à 10h
le matin du 11 septembre quand ch et
romsfield ont fait implémenter les
provisions de continue
le résultat c'est que nous
avons l'état public quiue
comme auparavant mais nous avons
maintenant un deuxième état un état
sécré ou comme on commence à dire de
plus en plus un état profond qui n'est
pas gouverné par le
Cour suprême qui fait ses proes loi
euh il y a maintenant des des des
questions très techniques où je je vais
pas
entrer dans ces problèmes dans ce
discours mais c'est pas seulement
moi-même qui parle d'un état profond
maintenant aux États-Unis et même des
gens de des des académiciens qui parlent
qu'il y a eu une coup un coup
d'État le 11 septembre parce que c'est
un tel changement de la condition
politique du pays c'est vrai qu'il faut
faire
des euh des reconnaître des similitudes
avec la situation dans l'Allemagne de
l'Est et pour un pays comme l'Amérique
qui était qui
était qui est né dans des
conditionitions de euh révolution contre
un gouvernement
absolutiste à Londes qui n'écoutait pas
les intérêts locals c'est c'est vrai
c'est vraiment dramatique de voir le
changement qu'on a vu dans ce
pays c'est très triste c'est
triste mais c'est triste
mais il faut pas penser que le
public est mort que la public oublié
l'idée de la
liberté c'est très difficile de
généraliser au de la condition des
États-Unis et le moment qu'on pense
qu'on a comprend ce qui passe aux
États-Unis c'est le moment que un
nouveau mouvement paraît ailleurs qu'on
n'attendait pas et c'est pour ça j'ai je
n'ai aucune fois que le gouvernement va
corriger la condition des conditions
actuellement actuelles mais j'ai
vraiment confiance qu'il y aurait enfin
un changement qui
proviendra du public des gens comme moi
et mes copains dans le
mouvement
[Musique]
antig-uerre des types comme kusac il y
en a pas il y en a pas beaucoup cette
espèce d'aplon incroyable avec lequel
les les yeux dans les yeux de tout le
monde il a dit je ne mens pas vous
pouvez me croire et cetera il y avait un
truc comment peut-on imaginer que un
politicien va être en mesure de se dire
non non attendez l'intérêt général c'est
la défense des libertés fondamentales
liberté fondamentale c'est la défense de
la vie privée et là il y a un
conflit c'est impossible d'appel les
haœurs en France le problème c'est que
le mot à cœur est est diabolisé on
oublie simplement que ce sont des gens
qui qui privilégie les résultats sur les
méthodes et qui sont capables de gagner
une connaissance intime d'un système